silent hill screenshots have allegedly
leaked and the jedi fallen order sequel
reportedly has a name
four alleged silent hill images leaked
by a twitter user called aesthetic gamer
also known as dusk golem have since been
taken down by a dmca request while
people were doubting if the images were
real the copyright claim suggests that
the leaks might be the first image shows
a dirty room with lots of trash and
peeling wallpaper in the second image a
woman stares at the viewer with the
words minger and i hate myself written
on her face the first term is british
slang and implies that the game's
setting will be in the uk or at least
something uk related will make an
appearance at the time of this recording
all four images can still be found on
reset era forums in their original tweet
aesthetic gamer wrote that the source
had given them enough proof to believe
the shots were real aesthetic goes on to
give the names anita and maya claiming
the shots are from 2020. over on reset
era aestheticgamer also claimed that
sony is still involved and that konami
was the one who filed the dmca a former
konami employee tom hewlett wrote on
twitter quote if a studio has multiple
people sending materials to a known
leaker they are not professional enough
to do the game justice a subsequent
tweet adds quote to be fair i tweeted
this partially as proof these leaks are
fake i don't believe them i've already
seen people claiming that i'm confirming
them as true i do not work for konami
and have not in nearly 10 years i do not
have special secret knowledge about
silent hill as you can imagine
speculations are flying abound about
which studio exactly is producing the
new silent hill game popular names
include developer bloober team since the
company is said to be partnering with
konami on new projects nothing's
confirmed yet though so we'll have to
wait for more information something else
that isn't confirmed yet is the name of
the star wars fallen order sequel but
according to grubsnack's host jeff grubb
the subtitle will be survivor at the end
of the may 12 2022 grub snacks episode a
viewer guessed the title of the game as
a part of a guessing game that grubb had
been playing with his chat once the
correct title was guessed grubb asked if
someone had told them that before
confirming that the title he's heard for
the game is indeed star wars jedi
survivor if the title is true it would
be an appropriate one because well if
you beat star wars jedi fall in order
you know why the sequel to fallen order
was confirmed by ean star wars back in
january when the companies announced
that respawn would be leading
development on not one but three
upcoming star wars titles these games
include the sequel to fall in order a
strategy game and a first person shooter
but okay hit the comment section and let
me know what you're playing this weekend
and if you got nothing but your own pc
then make sure you grab your free copy
of the 2017 prey from the epic game
store personally i still haven't beat
the game but i can tell you that it has
an awesome intro i'll see you next week
you